these guys sent me some [__] deserved
scale stuff about people who are high on
the Discovery deserve it deserve it
scales it's a drunk
um let's look at some of these here
I haven't looked at these yet
oh wow
oh that's so funny dude
guy gets so mad walking at the person I
don't know why and he's so mad and he
walks into a pole
looks like Santa and he's so mad no it's
so this is the classic example of
someone taking something out on some
someone because something else happened
he's mad this guy's walking across the
car he's yelling at the guy and he walks
into a pole and after he walks into a
pole he gets even more mad at the guy uh
so displaced
wow
love it
I love it
you're such a [__] hoe I love it
how come they can make music like that
hey oh dude oh have you seen this one I
kind of
caught up with who were jogging
first of all this is already so goddamn
boring
like don't catch up with anyone jogging
you know
oh go you oh you got joggers opinions
oh hold up
hey joggers what do you think
how boring are joggers
so it's so snowy here and this is the
Metro weather
somewhere WSU Vancouver Vancouver all
Saturday events are canceled
so we're catching up with some joggers
and they're still jogging even though
it's snowing so the deserve at scale is
at an all-time high because don't jog
when everything is canceled because of
weather but these people are like you
know what
we've got swept up in the moment we're
the kind of guys that's that sleep with
El Capitano in Italy we're the kind of
guys that think burgers in Amsterdam are
the best
with Chelsea and Michael who are jogging
by and we're nice to just stop for a
quick second and I said what are you
doing running and you're saying it was
really good out it's the perfect texture
for running very little hey you [__]
yoga teacher dude
are you [__] me
you might as well have just said I don't
eat meat that's all I talk about because
you're so annoying the perfect texture
for running
the per first of all honestly anytime
someone says the word texture is you're
unless you're a [__] you lay tile
you're an [__]
you know
the perfect texture for my guess is the
perfect texture for face planting too
because I have a feeling that's what's
going to be happening the perfect
texture for running very
let me guess if the cuck agrees
your feet don't get wet oh what have you
seen while you've been out running it's
been a lot of fun there's a lot of other
Runners and more skiers than Runners for
sure I think they've got a little bit of
the advantage with the whole stride and
glide thing but it's too nice to not be
out here yeah dude
it's snowing
it's snowing man
incredible though just to see
you on their bicycles yeah I don't know
how they do with the bikes like braking
uh well you're doing it running just go
inside man watch Seinfeld
we can control you know at worst case we
can fly right through a stop signing
worst case dude this guy it's so high on
the deserve at scale because it's
snowing and he's talking about they're
talking about how the texture is good
for running and they want to [__] be
you know what [__] it we're not going to
let the weather hold us back even though
it's not safe to do it and also he's
being so cocky about it
I mean listen to the [__] he's saying
look you know I don't know how they do
with the bikes like braking at least we
can control you know at worst case we
can just like giving the bikers a little
bit hey man got to give them credit even
though he thinks deep down he's getting
the credit you know what I mean because
like he he's like let me just like pass
off the credit to the bikers who really
are the heroes this guy [__] knows
people the the people who are like the
the followers are gonna be like well you
know but you're the real hero you don't
even use a bike though I tell you and
that's the hard thing and this guy knows
that those people are out there so this
deservative scale is off the charts dude
they're bicycles
they do with the bikes yeah bro uh
because then he thinks we're gonna think
well we don't know how you do it without
the bikes
control you know
the snow
this much of it I think when we woke up
this morning we were definitely
surprised by how much there was they
were sort of joking but it was a nice
dusting but the reality is this is a
this is a real chunk of snow giving Hood
let me just tell you let me just ask you
right now if you're listening to this
right now and not watching it on the
video guess if these people are white
money
California kids so we haven't had many
snow days in our life so this is pretty
exciting all right
we're on the run I'm sorry to have kept
you but I appreciate you guys talking
with us all right thanks we've seen a
lot of people out here like you said
running sledding just enjoying it one
thing oops she that can happen
unfortunately
and she ate [__]
oops that can happen unfortunately ah
okay
thanks scientists we've seen a lot of
people out here like he said running
sledding just enjoying it one thing oops
that can happen unfortunate dude the
background oh is so sad I feel bad
actually because she looked like she
heard I wish he fell
I don't like when the girl falls capture
but I appreciate you guys talking with
us all right thanks we've seen a lot of
people out here like he said running
sledding just enjoying it one thing oops
that can happen
I love the [__] well of course behind
the oops in the in the newscaster oops
oops
that can happen
knew these people were idiots and you
can tell
listen to the oops how much she knew
sorry to have kept you but I appreciate
you
all right thanks we've seen a lot of
people out here like he said running
sledding just enjoying it one thing oops
that can happen oh God you know
that oops is great let's look at YouTube
comments one of my favorite things oh
look how do you like the texture now
Sadiq
oh wow people are crazy huh
cameraman is OG for continuing to film
them
it's actually funny because I did think
about like well that's odd how he's
filming him for so long
dry snow you know
when people say dry snow hey do you know
what snow is
water
here's another one deserve it scale
let's see what this one is
I've never seen this one okay guy is
running full speed at night first of all
never run full speed at night because
you can't see all right you're running I
mean this guy is running full speed oh
he's streaking in the quad oh he's at
school
all right
in the glass like he's a [__] Yorkie
right in the glass
like he's a dog
like he's a beagle
oh full speed I had into the [__]
glass what look at that I mean you know
what's [__] so not funny streaking
you just like
[Music]
the people in the court it's like a
tennis call he was going to try and run
through the tennis court but there was
glass the people in there were just like
what the [__] is this [__] doing like
so didn't give him a reaction
wow
what's here
oh I already love this one oh wow okay
so when someone thinks they're badass
that's the best so this guy
camera on him
just filming his buddy walking
and he's dancing a little bit oh no does
he get hit by a car
oh I can't watch this
I mean he's doing like dancing
[Applause]
[Music]
okay don't watch that one because the
guy maybe died
he definitely didn't die but also don't
look at that one that one was so [__]
they gotta be funny guys I mean who you
[__] saying anything long and hard do
what you gotta do
dude oh I've seen this one she [__]
Rockets the thing she's pulling back the
Catapult thing it goes right in the
guy's face for her face just focus I'm
not giving up I'm just getting
frustrated like like why is this a thing
taking watermelons catapulting them
across super close
oh
oh my God right in the kisser show that
guy who's the boss whose boss flies
forward comes back smashes her in her
own face okay so she died
hey guys don't send the ones where they
die
okay
why did nobody react too they just went
oof hey the girl died